good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today
is scp-2875
object class
ketter
special containment procedures
a perimeter is to be established two
kilometers from the center of
wisconsin and no non-foundation
personnel are to pass this limit mobile
task force lambda 2 chain gang is to
oversee containment of scp-2875
updated containment procedures
due to recent findings only mobile task
force lambda 2 approved equipment is
considered acceptable to dispatch
scp-2875-a instances under no
circumstances are any personnel to
attempt to dispatch an instance of
scp-2875-a with a firearm incendiary
device or other unauthorized implement
description
scp-2870
is a phenomenon occurring only in the
town of wisconsin at noon every three
days between 50 to 100 fully grown adult
versus arctos herbalists mainland
grizzly bear will appear throughout the
town these instances are not anomalously
strong or fast or anomalously hostile
and will generally act like any other
members of their species given the
situation
the phenomenon appears to be cumulative
the instances scp-2875-a
will linger around the town's center for
a short time before dispersing and more
instances will appear three days later
due to the potential scaling issues of
the bear population growth it has become
imperative to dispatch the new instances
as quickly as possible
currently the only feasible means to
dispatch scp-2875-a
instances is by using a highly
concentrated aerosol tranquilizer spray
and then a blunt instrument with which
to cause trauma to the cranial region as
killing any of the instances using a
firearm or incendiary device results in
two new instances appearing next to the
corpse of the deceased instance as such
only foundation's standard motorized
blunt force devices have been permitted
for use against the instances with other
blunt or bladed weapons being permitted
per a mobile task force leader
instruction
discovery
scp-2875 was discovered by foundation
containment teams sent to investigate
reports about the sudden disappearance
of an entire town of people upon
arriving it
the situation quickly became apparent
when the town was observed as being
flooded with scp-2875-a
instances initially the containment
teams had prepared to move all of the
instances to other habitats outside of
but when the reoccurring nature of
scp-2875 was discovered the current
containment procedures were established
mobile task force lead note
i know plenty of you think that this is
some kind of joke but a town of
constantly appearing bears is serious
can you imagine what would happen to the
local ecosystem if we let this thing go
it was like a goddamn bear arena when we
first rolled in and that was only after
a few days
addendum 2875 won
collected voicemails
the following voicemails were recovered
from a mobile device found in a cave
outside
the owner of the device has not yet been
verified
2875 1.1
oh hey this is tom miller from city hall
and i just wanted to get in touch with
you about some things you were saying
the other day at the old town meeting uh
so
give me a call back here for too long my
number is uh
875-7112 and i'll talk to you then
thanks a lot bye
28.75 1.2
oh hey it's uh tom tom miller again from
city hall
i just wanted to get back in touch with
you about some things we talked about
the other day i've been thinking about
what you're saying about the best
problem with the coyotes but i really do
think bears is the way we want to go so
let me know when we can talk about that
get some plans laid out
you know my number is eight seven five
seven one one two we'll talk more though
thanks a lot bye
28.75 1.3
hey it's uh tom miller again just wanted
to let you know bears is going great we
haven't seen any coyotes around in a
while so that's good
i do have one question though about one
of the bears getting a little close to
town
one of the gals in town is a little
freaked about it so
we can talk about that and get some of
these details ironed out i think this is
going to be great
okay thanks a lot
oh yeah uh the number is eight seven
five seven one one two and we'll talk
thanks a lot bye
28.75 1.4
hey there it's uh tom miller again
haven't heard from you in a while i just
wanted to let you know me and some of
the guys are a little concerned that
there might be too many bears most of
the coyotes have moved on from town so
it's
probably about time the bears got out of
here
so we got to do that pretty soon it's
becoming a little bit of a problem so
give me a call the number is 875-7112
i hope to talk to you soon
bye
28.75 1.5
okay listen there are too many bears in
town now
a little boy got attacked just the other
day in the street he was with his mom
he got attacked by one of the bears okay
there are too many bears now
i need you to call me please as soon as
you can so we can do something about
this
okay
thanks
oh wait
eight seven five seven one one two okay
call me soon thanks bye
28.75 1.6
okay listen there's a bear outside of my
house okay my neighbor just got eated by
a bear okay there are bears in the
streets there are bears in people's
homes okay we gotta do something about
this there's
i can't get outside okay my kids are at
school i can't get to my kids
okay there's a bear on my car wicket oh
god
oh lord there's a bear in my house
oh 875 7112
[Applause]
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
ian j allsup
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
savanity
kristoff kozak slesak
hms lily
the almighty fish
gav the clumsy containment specialist
spooky aqua
pure osmium
sciodio damnatis
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
drew peacock eric corbidge
longinus
james saba
and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you